hello and welcome to the new old review
your source for everything anime manga
and today we are back with some more
black clover review style things or i
guess things singular because it's just
one but this just one thing happens to
be the hot springs training camp arc the
shortest since our initial outings in
the series but a great experience with a
ton of character development and
in-world
intrigue to be had it's definitely not
quite what i was expecting when i first
heard the name of the arc but as always
if you are enjoying these videos then
please do activate your finger motion
and direct it towards both the like and
subscribe buttons because i can't
really read comments due to spoilers but
i can see numbers so if you want more of
this
allegedly black clover then don't forget
to do the thing but starting with the
premise of the arc it starts out almost
exactly the same as the eye of the
midnight sun arc with aster being
ordered to take some time off except
this time instead of becoming embroiled
in an epic clash against wildly powerful
magic smiths we actually do take the
time to breathe and go to a festival
followed by a brief burst of training
and on paper that's kind of that
and as sort of mundane as it sounds i
really appreciated it and i think it
worked quite well
firstly because it breaks the now
established black clover pattern we got
through a handful of medium-sized darks
that all had very similar constructive
tissue you know we get a call to action
explore a new location face off against
an enemy far greater than anyone was
prepared for defeat them anyway and then
move on to do it all again which isn't
to say that's a bad thing because tabata
tweaks that formula just enough to keep
things interesting but this 10 chapter
arc is very much what i was looking for
right about now and it made me aware of
something very intriguing actually which
is that the characters of this series
are just so strong that we don't
actually need a conflict or big bad
enemies to make black clover captivating
because i really was more than happy
just following all of our protagonistic
misfits and watching them interact with
each other for this block of time and in
many ways it was almost like reading a
more light-hearted high school comedy
series so that was a cool change of pace
and it was great to take some time to
breathe and have fun after this string
of massive action pieces but our first
point to focus here was the star
festival an annual event where we get to
find out which of the magic knight
squads impressed senpai the most and
earned the greatest amount of delicious
star merits and there was some very
expected stuff here for example the
golden dawn obviously won and yuno was
obviously recognized for his absurdly
great rookie efforts what i did not
expect was for the black bulls to rank
smack bang in second place when the
ceremony began i thought to myself that
they'd either still be last but with a
positive amount of stars or that they
would beat a single squad and still be
just as shocked as they ultimately were
to come second
screw that though we're jumping straight
into second place which seems a bit
sudden but at the same time i believe
the wizard king said that astor was now
16 as of the time of this festival which
i think means that a whole year has
already passed since we received the
grimoire and joined the black bulls
which is kind of wild because my
perception of time was something like i
don't know a few months but i do like it
one of my personal annoyances when it
comes to shona manga is not having that
passage of time or a super slow passage
like a my hero academia sort of feel
where after almost 300 chapters deku is
still in his first year of high school
or food wars where the vast majority of
it also takes place in soma's first year
but then again i have to say i'm also a
pretty massive hypocrite because i love
one piece and the first
almost 600 chapters of that basically
play out over the course of a few months
so
yeah in conclusion i like that astor is
older and that time is progressing at a
nice pace and me being me i also really
enjoyed seeing the list of all the
reasons why the stars were awarded this
is the kind of little detail that
tabitha really did not need to include
he could have just thrown a total amount
up there and it would have been just as
effective but i like that he took the
time to work out in great detail where
the golden dawn specifically earned all
of their stars and of course this arc
actually marks a major step forward for
the astor yuna rivalry because both of
them get recognized on stage by mr
wizard king
and they well they decide to show off a
bit in order to win the favor or at
least respect of the crowd and this is a
much bigger moment than any kind of
power
up or increase in rank because here you
have the wizard king very publicly
raising their profiles
and practically holding them up as the
base standard of the magic knight system
so we're starting to break through the
discrimination aspect of them being
lowly peasantry or at least with the
general crowd anyway although to be fair
the crowd here are just kind of upper
class plebs themselves
most of them aren't high high nobility
so i'm sure there's still an extremely
prevalent faction of noble supremacy
which sure speaking of we get to meet
the uh the actual king during this arc
a very very disappointing man by the
name of augustus kira clover viii
who spends most of his time here
commanding to be glorified simply due to
the achievement of existing and all i
can really say is that he looks acts and
sounds exactly like i was expecting
especially the looks he's such a
standard royal
king dude bro almost like he was pulled
straight out of a box of a children's
court playset so i actually find him
quite boring as a result i think that
tabitha could have gone to some more
extremes with his design you know make
him a lot uglier or even a lot prettier
just something to make him actually
stand out
unless of course that's the whole point
a purposely boring and underwhelming
figurehead of nobility
i don't know even then i just i don't
care for him like it's not even that i
don't like him i just don't
care at all for the king currently it's
very neutral however the king did have
something interesting to say though
which i imagine seeds a future rock
which is that he plans to build a force
of royal knights and have them directly
attack the eye of the midnight sun which
brings up questions ever so many
questions some of which posed directly
by astor
for example why should we be under your
command for such an important task when
we have a much more capable military
leader in the wizard king and also at
least one from me being
what is even the point of going through
this test surely if you wanted to do
something like this you just
instruct the majority of the magic
knights to do so because they're already
kind of under your command as king and
if you did indeed want some kind of
super squad then just scoop up all of
the captains maybe the vice captains
and form it that way so beyond being a
[ __ ] i really don't quite get the
purpose of what the king is doing here
at the moment but i'm sure his
motivations will become clearer in the
future or not i'm actually not sure of
that so i shouldn't say that but i did
and re-recording it would be a mild
inconvenience so
i'm not going to redo it but something
else i wanted to highlight from the star
festival though is the appearance of
kyoto and kohono
it was nice to see them again and have
them healed by the blood magic of the
witch queen
but it was also kind of annoying because
the whole thing with the underwater
temple was that they had dreams of
traveling to the surface
and being performers but were unable to
do so for unspecified reasons
they just you know weren't allowed to go
to the capitol because it was
and i quote against the rules but here
they both are
in the capital and it's one of those
things where it could have been fixed
with just one line saying something like
our grandfather gave us permission to
travel to the capital for this one day
or just
something anything i'm still kind of
annoyed that we never really got to
explore the culture of the sea folk or
find out why they were so purposely
self-isolated but after the whole star
festival business things get very
suddenly amazing with the introduction
of a certain maria leona vermillion who
from here on out i will only refer to as
cisco leon because it's much easier to
say
and it's kind of adorable but i really
do love this whole family the vermillion
family and the crimson lions are easily
one of my favorite factions in the
series and cisco leon does not
disappoint at all i love her fiery
nature i thought it was hilarious that
she managed to conscript everyone
including two magic knight captains into
her scheme and i really do like that she
managed to continue the whole fuegoleon
legacy of inspiration i mean cisco leon
is certainly much more
brutal than fuego leon but she managed
to push both astor and noel in exactly
the right direction very much mirroring
the actions of her brother except i
suppose actually fuego leon influenced
both aster and noewell with profound
words meanwhile cisco leon did the same
but mostly through action which was a
nice contrast and in fact noelle herself
took quite a few steps forward in this
very short 10 chapters both with the
aforementioned growth with cisgolian but
also coming to her own philosophical
view on nobility and i find it a very
interesting thing that noel has chosen
to embrace her noble heritage because
usually in this sort of story the
other good noble characters would
generally come to abandon that side of
them you know the whole idea of we're
all equal so i shall cast aside
my nobility and such but here in noel's
case she chooses to recognize that
everyone is not indeed equal
she has been granted a greater level of
power than most and so she now sees it
as her having a great responsibility to
use that power to help those without it
so it's a very nice spin on the royal
character trope and after noel said that
i had the exact same reaction as aster
where i was like huh
i guess i do like noel quite a bit and
there was some more information dropped
about noel's mother the steel warrior
princess which basically represents the
polar opposite of what noel is with her
magic said to be dignified beyond all
belief
and i want to know more about her a lot
more about her because she seems like
quite a legendary figure of pure
awesomeness
and weirdly enough the more i learn
about noelle's mother the easier it
may become to empathize with noah's
siblings who to be clear are still
complete and utter bricks but there is
definitely a harsh reckoning to come to
terms with when it involves not only the
sacrifice of your mother but one of the
kingdom's greatest mages and i don't
know if black clover is the kind of
series that would go that deep but i can
see where the really twisted psyche
kicks in there and it also does put
tremendous pressure on noel to live up
to her mother's legacy a task which she
seems to have embraced and i do look
forward to seeing her progress further
and as for aster i think it's also
important to note that he seems to have
discovered a mechanism to activate his
uh well i suppose i don't
really know what to call it yet a
partial transformation leopold calls it
black aster which sure
that's fine i do like how key was worked
into it which is still
a little bit of a weird subsystem to me
but yeah whatever let's go with it and
someone else who got expanded upon quite
a bit would be the captain of the blue
rose charlotte and at the very least as
a result i can
kind of get on board with her yummy
obsession now charlotte and vanessa
actually have
shockingly similar yummy backstories
where he just stumbles in and saves them
from whatever hell they're trapped in
before casually wandering back out i do
wish that charlotte was treated a bit
more like a captain though and less like
comic relief although i do have to admit
that there was this great panel at the
end of the arc where she
was all flustered at the thought of yami
being gasped naked but i do wish that
the army obsession wasn't currently her
defining characteristic i mean for
example i really don't like noel's
sunday obsession with asta but at the
very least that part of her is always
secondary to noelle's primary
story focus which is learning to control
her power and living up to her family's
legacy but with charlotte everything is
very much geared towards yami because
her curse is directly tied to him having
stolen her heart
and yeah i don't know right now i just
find her much less interesting than most
other
characters in the series but when
everything is said and done which is
about now this was a great little minion
i applaud tamita for taking the time to
just sit and dwell on some interactions
between our main caster protagonists
whilst also finding a way to incorporate
a hell of a lot of development into it
not just emotional either because
everyone present at the training camp
got a lot of power development as well
and we got to do all of it without a
single battle required so it was a
pleasant break and some much needed
variety for the series and as a result i
feel rested rejuvenated and more than
ready to tackle our next challenge but
that pretty much does it for this blind
review of the hot springs training camp
arc and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you are keen for some more black
clover content then please do go and
check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for very
maybe regular black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time